governor gavin newsom to face recall
election as republican-led effort hits
signature goal l.a times propelled by
growing voter frustration over
california's response
to covet 19 pandemic republican-led
drive to remove governor newsom from
office collected enough voter
registration to qualify
for the ballot state official reported
monday triggering for only the second
time in state history a rapid fire
campaign to decide whether or
whether to oust a sitting governor
recall backers submitted more than 1.495
verified voter registration equal to 12
of our ballot cast in the last guber
national election meeting the minimum
threshold to force a special recall
election according to a tally released
by secretary of
state shirley weber two and a half years
ago newsome won the governor
office by the largest margin of modern
history capping the telegenic democratic
steady rise to the pinnacle of
california politics
that began in 1996 when san francisco
mayor willie brown appointed him
to the city's parking and traffic
commission
so when you do that this is what happens
what are the voters in california
responding to
to the way you managed a crisis
called covet now the people get to vote
kai can you pull up that article i sent
to you
pull up that article i sent you this is
this is interesting to look at and this
kind of leads me to the next two links
that i sent to you that's
the reuters one but let's not go to
reuters yet first go to the newsome
article i sent you
uh that shows what percentage of
democrats supported and didn't support
but anyways adam what do you think about
this
i mean with newsome yeah i mean what
there's a couple different lessons here
number one is a fall from grace i mean
he had the largest margin of victory
since what when did they say since 96
so you're talking about a guy who was
beloved you know i don't want to use
that term
too loosely but very liked and now
even democrats are like yeah dude this
guy i mean come on man
not so much and i think ultimately your
point is crisis management how are you
handling a crisis you're going to be
dealing with the crisis
no matter what state you're in no matter
what country you're in how do you
respond to that like how many times it's
kind of like
you know you can fall you get knocked
down 10 times get up
get up 11. he
mismanaged this crisis completely i know
he was the
i know we joke he was the you all
employee of the year
and um that he was uh what's the
laundry the restaurant in in san
francisco he was eating out he was
thinking
so what caused this so what caused this
one is hypocrisy you're telling me to
stay home but you're at french laundry
okay you're telling me not to put any
parties but you're going to a party with
350 people with no one wearing a mask
okay you're you're messing with elon
musk and you're telling them they can't
work what elon musk calls you out then
you eventually say okay you guys can get
to work and elon musk leaves
you have the number one podcaster in the
world a guy named joe rogan you end up
losing him
okay you got a guy whose
oracle is sitting there the guy's upset
so he
you know has plans of leaving you got
companies that are wanting to leave
their headquarters to a different place
you got a city like san francisco that
the world loves going to to stay for
vacation one of our favorite places to
go to
now it's a mess there's a website saying
what places poops
sitting around when you're walking the
city of san francisco there's a poop
watch website
for san francisco how pathetic is that
and you're the governor not the mayor
not a congressman not a senator you're
essentially the president of the sixth
largest economy in the world and you've
screwed up the last 12 months
and you were so excited to impeach the
president twice
guess what now it's coming back now it's
coming back at you
and you don't like it and here's what he
had to say yesterday if you can pull up
his tweet i send a tweet to you as well
kai i don't know if you have it
uh his tweet says the republican record
by the way i want to actually watch that
video as well so hold the video we'll go
to it in a second to raise the volume i
want everybody to watch the video as
well
yeah but hang tight on that video you
can actually uh yeah the republican
recall threatens our values and seeks to
undo the important progress we've made
from fighting covey to helping
struggling families protect our govern
our protect our environment and passing
common sense gun violence solutions
there is too much at stake
he doesn't get a lot of likes you get a
ton of comments
not enough tweets can you flip the
screen there you go to do it that way if
you can make that screen bigger and play
the video
and tell me if this is a motivational
video or scaring the hell out of your
video what
what kind of a movie is this watch this
go ahead and knew some
anti-vaccine q and on extremists violent
white supremacists like the proud boys
who attacked our nation's capital on
january 6
and the same right-wing republican
politicians who supported donald trump's
attempt to overturn the election
of course paid for by the republican
national committee
instead of helping fight the pandemic
national republicans are coming to fight
californians stop the republican recall
it's a power grab who's behind
or not so where's the responsibility why
are they not going after other liberal
states
why are they coming after you okay so
matt what do you think about it it's uh
it's uh so to answer your first question
it is a fear-based uh
fear-based type of ad campaign okay go
back to the main article please
go ahead you know when i was stationed
when i was stationed in california is a
united states marine i
we love southern california southern
california uh
dana point newport beach area san diego
and one
one thing i've it's always befuddled me
as i was growing my business i got at
the military started growing my business
in california
is chicago's got some horrible traffic
but l.a damn yeah that is some traffic
options
and and all i'm thinking when i think
about one word when i think about
california i think one word i think
bottleneck
so many things are bottlenecked over
there it's it's sadly poorly run
nobody trusts the public school system
there in california everything's about
the private school in california
uh you know when you think about these
businesses and even
parts of hollywood who's also recruiting
people out of uh california is um tyler
uh perry he's creating hollywood to
shoot movies in his uh georgia location
yeah yeah beautiful canadas by the way
and so when when you're thinking about
that
you have this great opportunity i think
you mentioned something a lot when
you're when you're coaching us
pbd he said you forget what it's like to
be the new guy
i wonder if you forgot what it was like
to be that new guy in 1996 when he
supported the
parking and traffic commission i
remember what it feels like to be just a
normal citizen again because sometimes
when you have that element of power and
you're sitting there in sacramento
you're sitting there as a governor
number one in charge you kind of forget
what it's like to relate to a brand new
person they're struggling
in that la traffic my thoughts i can see
that what are you saying anything else
you know being that i'm a florida boy
born and raised in miami and i lived in
all throughout florida it's i actually
had this conversation with ricky
and uh when last time when we had dinner
and i basically completely understood
why he's
so anti-democratic party
uh where i was like dude we're we're i'm
my point is this there's a big
difference between a florida democrat
and a california democrat just like
there's a big difference between being a
california republican
and an alabama republican so i think
part of the problem in this country is
that
when you're so far left or you're so far
right
the best ideas don't win the best ideas
typically win in florida because we're a
purple state
and you and people are like well you
know i could go this way i can maybe
think this way
and at ten 10 movement of the
uh voting block could actually determine
an election
you can do you could be the best
republican candidate
in california and unless your name is
arnold schwarzenegger it's going to be
very hard to win anything because i'm
guessing
70 of the voting contingency uh
constituency
in california is going to be democrats
so you have to convert
20 just to get to 50
so can you get to the bottom of the
article that shows how many democrats
voted for this it's the link i sent you
is this the one i sent you yeah keep
going keep going keep going keep there
it is right there
okay flip the screen to go on the big
screen guys instead of being on me
make it a little bit bigger make it a
little bit bigger go
control plus doesn't do it okay there
you go
how california and different parties
would vote on the newsome recall as of
march 30th only 40
likely voters said they vote yes to
remove governor while about eight in 10
republicans would vote
to remove new some eight in 10 democrats
would vote to keep him and look at that
all likely voters 40
won this guy out 15 percent of democrats
so that video they said about uh
you know uh it's only republicans
republican funded no no no no
fifteen percent of democrats in the
state of
yep california they want you at 79
republicans i understand want you out
42 percent of independents want you out
by the way you know which
which of those uh three matters the most
to get along far and away independent of
course
yeah and 40 percent of one shot they're
not talking about
that ad that they purpo republicans this
no no no
42 percent of independents want you out
so it's not a republican thing
it's an independent thing who wins
president elections
independence correct independence the
vote you want to win the presidential
election correct
that tells you everything here right
because so they can say them anything
they want with the videos and all this
other stuff
nope it's not just the republicans but
you always talk about that 46
of people are going to vote democrat 44
of people are going to vote republican
that's it like is that the number forty
fourteen sixteen
forty four forty two forty four forty
two point is that it's
low to mid forties you're locked in bro
you're not a free thinker this is
it is what it is it's baked in the cake
i don't wanna hear what the other side
has to say
i don't give a [ __ ] if they're right if
they're wrong i'm voting for trump
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm going for a bite
it is what it is
and i think what our country needs and
yearns for in any time that we talk
about
a third-party candidate would you vote
for the rock would you vote for
mcconaughey well may [ __ ]
be because independent thinking
is probably the best course of action at
this point because
if you're just too dead set on an ideal
and not i'm sorry on a candidate and not
an actual set of ideals
then you you can't be swayed and your
free thinking doesn't matter that'd be
an interesting thing to see if
the rock actually votes i'm sorry he
actually runs for president
and how many votes he would actually
bring would you would you think he'd run
into democratic
platforms i think it would be a democrat
okay i think you should probably have a
republican uh
vice president okay that could be smart
i'd like to see something like that so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye